Film Courage: This question comes in from
Stian Kallhovd (forgive me for saying the
name incorrectly) “I’ve sometimes wondered
whether I should write TV series in addition
to features, but so far it seems to me that
the stories I want to tell are better told
through films. Can Russell give an example
of why a story would be better told as a TV
series?
Peter Russell, screenwriter/story doctor:
Well if you love movie and so many people
do I know a lot of people who grew up loving
movies are kind of appalled that television
has taken over.
Think of it this way you can tell any movie
as a TV miniseries. You can take the movie
that you’ve been writing over the last four
or five years and you can turn it into a television
miniseries more easily than you can turn it
into a TV series. So think of it that way.
Now I spent several years learning genres:
mystery thriller, crime thriller, horror,
all of these genres and I sort of master the
deep understanding of each one of those genres
and every one of those genres is very different
and they all have these cool tools that I
learned to help movie people. Well guess what?
It turns out when I turn my attention to television,
all the rules of movie thrillers apply to
the crime drama that I’m selling as a serial
right now Ray Donovan meets True Detective.
All of those cool structural tools that work
in SEVEN, that work in all these classic movies,
it turns out those secrets transfer right
over to television.
So just know that everything you’ve learned
about movies works in TV. But the easiest
transition is to take your movie idea and
turn it into a miniseries. Why? Which for
some of the reasons we talked about earlier
which is miniseries are like long movies because
the characters have an arc. They start with
a wound and they eventually heal or not.
So if you’re writing movies and you love
movies, make the transition to television
by writing a miniseries, where you can simply
stretch your idea into a longer form. Forget
the structure so much, but those cool tools
which by the way I have on my website Peter
Russell Script Doctor (dot) com. I go each
genre of movies has a set of hidden structures
and tools in it. Just take those hidden structures
and tools and apply them to your television
show in the same genre.
Writing a comedy? Apply the movie comedic
rules to your sitcom. Writing a romantic comedy,
same thing. Love story, same thing. Adventure
romance, same thing. Write a miniseries, it’s
a bridge form. It will help you learn why
television has two big differences than movies.
One is that the characters don’t really
change in television and the other is you
can tell more than you can in a movie where
you want to show everything (so there’s
just more dialogue).
But those are the two big differences, everything
else can be the same. Especially in a miniseries.
It’s a great bridge for you to learn this
new structure. And you’ll just have a better
chance of getting your story bought. I didn’t
say great chance! I said better chance because
I think we’re up to 550 scripted television
shows now in the U.S. A few years ago there
were 200. And I believe that’s going to
continue. I think in 10 years television is
going to be five times as big as it is right
now.
So if you want your work to sell learn the
new forms by bridging your way to TV by using
your movie as a miniseries.
Film Courage: We miniseries in fashion so-to-speak
previously?
Peter: They were in the 70’s. I know there
were big miniseries in the 70’s like the
THORN BIRDS. There was another show called
SHOGUN. These were big event television so
they’d be on one night for three or four
nights, five nights sometimes. But then there
was a period where they weren’t fashionable.
But they’ve gotten very fashionable again.
Ryan Murphy, all these guys that write these
fantastic shows. The OJ Simpson trial [THE
PEOPLE V. O.J. SIMPSON]. TRUST which is a
great one that Danny Boyle just did about
the Getty family, brilliant miniseries.
And THE ASSASSINATION OF GIANI VERSACE they
are where I think a lot of movie makers are
going in television because it’s a more
commodious form, it’s the easiest way to
transition from film to television.
And I think the miniseries also kind of satisfies
our desire for seeing a movie which is I want
to see somebody change, I want to see a complete
story right? When you’re watching ANIMAL
KINGDOM, well okay Ellen Barkin is still going
to be a poisonous b*tch, okay, well let’s
have some popcorn. At some point you want
to see what’s going to happen right? Can
we have some resolution, can we actually resolve
something. That’s what great movies have
always done for us, so I think that instinct
to have a complete story, that’s why miniseries
have become so much more popular. They’re
sort of replacing what movies used to give
us which is the sense of a complete story.
“Ahh, we’re done. Ellen Barkin is. Yeah,
two of the kids got help. They got therapy.
Thank God we can have dinner now.” As opposed
to “Oh God she’s still in jail, she’s
really tormented right. Is she still wearing
those awful black contacts, yes she is. She
still looks like, right?
In the movie, she would have moved on. She’d
probably be or should be okay. But that’s
why miniseries I think are so popular.
Film Courage: You said in the 70’s [miniseries]
were popular. Can you see any parallels between
that time and now? Is there something in audiences
that wants this?
Peter: Yes, I think that we love long form
entertainment. And that’s why I think we
binge series, too. I think entertainment is
becoming like the Russian novel of the 19th
century. What do I mean by this? It sounds
so pretentious, I’m sorry. But the Russian
novel (Tolstoy) got longer and longer and
bigger and bigger, until they were 1,000 pages,
1,500 pages, right?
That’s the sign of a maturity of an art
form. That’s when an art form gets its best,
when it gets big, when it gets long. I think
we’re in that we’re in that (Suzy hates
me saying The Golden Age) but I think we are
in a Golden Age of Entertainment because the
stories are getting so much longer. Look,
you can tell everybody is neither a good guy
or a bad guy. Everybody is at a combination
of traits in them.
So a movie can’t really show you that, there’s
not enough time. You’re either good or you’re
bad. Television and the longer form can show
both the good and the bad inside of all of
us. It’s a more sophisticated model of human
behavior. I think we’re just getting to
be more sophisticated as people to know that
people’s stories are complex. I’m not
all good. I’m not all evil. I’m mostly
evil but there’s some good in me but that’s
the mix. And so longer form art can give us
a more complete picture of what humanity is
about.